Matthew rice is printing off his
political identity not as he sees it but
how it looks according to the Liberal
Democrats with an election looming the
parties are building up their data war
chests Matthew used the new law to ask
the Lib Dems what they held on him we
got what we expected which was the
electoral data that we all sign up to if
we want to to vote but we also found a
series of scores and in fact there were
37 potential scores that could have been
attributed to me and I had nine values
ahead of a possible vote later this year
the Lib Dems scored Matthew 22% likely
to vote brexit party 20% likely to vote
conservative and 77% likely to vote
remain another referendum along with six
other similar scores this kind of
scoring is common for political parties
but new transparency laws give us an
unprecedented glimpse into how a major
party does it all the data they held on
me and they'd scored me - they've got me
as 54% pragmatic liberal whatever that
means they also guessed my age based on
my name
apparently I'm probably under it all
feels personal to make this course the
Lib Dems use data from canvassing and
web surveys as well as data they bought
on lifestyle and shopping habits but
it's the automated method they used to
generate the scores the worries data
protection experts it should be a matter
for the Information Commissioner's
Office to now look at this and to
investigate again the use of personal
data by political parties because that
profiling seems to me to be more
detailed more intense than the average
person would expect under their new
leader the Lib Dems are looking to gain
big at the next election
they said they needed the scoring system
to decide where to campaign they told us
they complied with all data protection
legislation including the principle of
transparency and stated clearly how
personal data was used in their privacy
policy although Matthew read that policy
and he was still surprised I asked him
why it's cause accurate doesn't matter
who I think I am what matters is who
they think I am and that leaves you a
little bit cool
it doesn't feel reflective of what you
would want from a democratic culture we
asked the Lib Dems who they assign
scores to they told us every eligible
voter the old rituals remain but in the
age of big data democracy risks coming
unstuck
Braham anthem sky news